using your brain too much is gonna hurt
yourself Adam Levine is playing coy
about his future with the voice there
was some confusion a few weeks ago your
teammates seem to think that or your
your team seems to think that you were
maybe gonna be getting ready to take
some time off we didn't know that Adam
would be leaving to have his family next
year so I mean it's so awesome to have
the opportunity to have him as a coach
balance family know what's happening at
the end like I'm gonna leave here and I
don't even know where I'm going I don't
I don't think that far ahead but we'll
see okay so you're not thinking about
how you're gonna balance the career and
the family and that yet no I you know
I've never thought I know I using your
brain too much is gonna hurt yourself
luckily for us Adam is using that brain
of his to work on new music
I want to know about the status of the
next maroon five album not an album
right now okay but maybe you saw him ok
gotta gotta keep gotta keep the kids
interested we have something something
going on right now okay any hints on a
timeline I don't know soon soon it's
coming thank you it's on the way Denis
it's in the incubator